[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK, great.
Thanks everyone for coming.
I'm really stoked
to be here today,
speaking to you at Cloud Next.
My name is Chris Broadfoot.
I'm an engineer on the
Developer Relations team,
and today I'm going to be
talking to you about minimizing
app latency at scale.
And I'll go into a little bit
about what I think that means.
I spoke to some people outside
as we were waiting to come in,
what it means to them
and what they are
trying to get out of this talk.
And there's little bits
for everyone, I hope.
But we'll generally be speaking
at a pretty high level.
I'm going to give you
some ideas and draw
on some of my
personal experiences
working on production
apps at Google.
Even though I'm in
developer relations,
I've had some side
projects, essentially 20%.
And I'll show you some real
graphs and screenshots too.
So notes and slides will
eventually be at this URL.
I'll be referencing
some things, and you'll
be able to find links
under that link.
So yeah.
Performance and latency is
a really difficult subject
to talk about at
this conference.
You might have noticed that
this talk is one of the few
that are sort of talking
about things at a high level.
We're not talking about specific
products or anything like that.
So you're probably a
really diverse audience
of mobile, web,
back-end developers.
There's probably some of
you in IT and ops as well.
So I'll be trying to keep
things sort of general
and give a bit of
information for everyone.
I'm going to take a
holistic approach, which
I think is generally the right
way to approach performance
and latency and
things like that.
So why are you here?
Why do we care about it?
You've probably
already acknowledged
that you care about latency,
because you're here or watching
this talk on YouTube.
This is a pretty famous
quote, and it's kind of become
a rule of thumb, I think.
So Greg Linden, who at
the time was at Amazon--
this was about 10 years
ago, I think, now--
found that a 100-millisecond
increase in page latency
caused about a 1%
drop in revenue.
And we're 10 years on now, but
I think these results are still
kind of correct,
and they've been
replicated across
multiple companies,
including Google and Bing.
And I'll have some links to
some references for this.
But yeah.
Does this really apply to you?
That's the question.
Does this apply to your app?
Obviously, if your app
doesn't have revenue,
then it doesn't at all, right?
OK.
Let's first define latency.
It's essentially the delay
between request and response.
But what's application latency?
You came here to this talk.
The title is "Minimizing
App Latency."
OK, I think it's
just a made-up term.
There are about 30,000
results on Google.
So I'm going to
define it here today.
So application latency,
I am proposing,
is the delay between a
user's action and update.
So this is essentially
a holistic UX thing.
So the latency is the time
the user presses a button
or initiates an action and
when they see a result.
So this is actually nothing to
do with networking or anything
like that, although
it is related.
When does it matter?
A good rule of thumb is
that your most common cases
should be faster.
So given a blog service,
viewing a blog post
is the most frequent
action, maybe.
A lot of people-- a lot of
blogs are not read very often.
Going down to viewing
the comments for a blog.
So maybe as you scroll
down, load those in later.
Commenting on a blog post,
and publishing and editing,
so essentially the
write operations.
And then finally, the
most infrequent operation
is creating a new blog,
although perhaps more blogs are
created than posts are created.
So that might be the wrong
thing to optimize for.
There's an interesting anecdote
which I think was from Blogger.
The blog creation process--
that is, creating
an entire new site--
was so fast that users thought
that something was wrong.
They would click Create
New Blog, and boom,
it would just happen.
And I think that left users
wondering whether something
really happened at all or not.
So sometimes fast is not better.
Optimize for user satisfaction
over everything else.
So we might be able to change
from frequent to infrequent,
to insignificant to
significant, right?
Maybe significant
operations are slower
because the user is
committing something,
so maybe they expect you to
commit something back, right?
So they expect
something to be slower.
So the next thing I
want to talk about
is managing user expectations.
When can you get away
with making things slow?
If you can't make
things fast, then
make the user understand
why things are slow.
I think we can all understand
that re-architecting
our applications in a
way to make things fast
is sometimes not possible.
So when can we get
away with slow things?
We already talked about
more infrequent operations.
Just telling the user
it's going to take
a while might be good enough.
And more importantly,
telling them
why it's going to take a while.
Giving users frequent
updates and indications
is also really good.
Tell them why it's
happening and what's
happening under the hood.
So an app that does
this really well
is just the BigQuery
user interface.
There could be some
improvements, obviously.
But what it does, when
you hit Run Query,
it just has a timer, a
stopwatch, that goes up.
And so this is giving
users some indication
that something is happening.
They don't really
know exactly what's
happening under the hood,
although once the job has
completed, you can see the
explanation for the query.
And it tells you,
importantly, how many
gigabytes were processed.
So it's telling you why this
operation took so long, right,
because we processed all
of these gigabytes of data.
So this sets user expectations.
They know they're
querying huge data sets,
but they're only
happening in 17 seconds,
whereas this operation,
obviously, something
taking 17 seconds might
not be appropriate
for other applications.
I'm thinking about game
servers or something
like that, where we're
talking tens of milliseconds
rather than tens of seconds.
So you have to consider
everything in context.
So breaking down, at a really
high level, application
latency, we can think of things,
so on the left of this slide,
would be the user
initiating an action,
and on the right, when
they see the actual update.
We have any network requests,
which I think a lot of people
here are concerned
about, which consists
of latency of the
requests going out,
whatever's happening
on the server,
and maybe dependent
servers from there,
and then the time it
takes to come back.
And there may be some sort
of on-device processing
like storing the results in
a local cache or database,
and then whatever happens in
the UI, so reflows and repaints.
These are all part of
application latency.
So this is what the
user experiences.
So one trick that
you might know is
to sort of decouple these
things to reduce the perceived
latency.
So maybe doing some
of this work upfront,
and sending off the network
request in the background.
A really good example of this
is anything with a Like button
or a +1 button or
something like that.
The UI updates instantaneously.
The app confirms that the
user performed an action,
and the network request
happens in the background.
So you might do some sort
of on-device processing
beforehand, like storing the
fact that the user initiated
this action, so that
you could possibly
retry the action in
future, or display
that the network request
failed, or something like that.
And I'm actually
using this graphic.
We're going to look
at each of these boxes
separately throughout the talk.
So we're actually going to
start more from the UI side.
We've been talking a
lot about UX stuff.
But yes, we will be
talking about networking
and things like that.
So how do you know what the
slow part of your app is?
We need to figure out what's
slow and how to fix it
and what the problems are.
Google Analytics does
this automatically
for web applications.
This is actually a real
app that I've worked on
of anonymize the page URLs.
But it gives you a
really nice indication
of several important statistics,
in this case, the document
interactive time, which
is when the page can
be interacted with.
So this is separate
from Dom content loaded,
if you're a web developer,
which I think is a poor metric.
This is a better metric.
So this is a really
simple way to figure out
which of your pages are slow.
So once you've figured
out which pages are slow,
using the Chrome Developer
Console or the equivalent
for Android or iOS
is a really good way
to figure out exactly
what's happening.
So this is actually
a timeline graph
of Gmail, which is an incredibly
complicated application.
So it shows you things
like what JavaScript
is running, what network
requests are happening,
and what paints and things
like that that are happening,
like compositors on the GPU,
things like that, so you
can figure out exactly
what's happening
inside your application.
Detecting the document
interactive time and Dom
content loaded are
good, but even better
is getting actual
timings from your users.
So you might have some sort
of lazy loading or something
like that.
With Google Analytics,
you can send these timings
to Google Analytics,
and you'll be
able to slice and dice it like
any other events or triggers
or anything that happens
inside Analytics.
So this is a really handy
way to customize your timings
once you've figured out exactly
what components of your page
or application that
you want to figure out.
So this is the same code
for Java, so on Android.
And you'll end up
in the analytics
with a graph like this.
So this is a real app, again.
So you get timing buckets.
The most interesting
thing, I think for me,
are the ones that
take the slowest.
I want to figure out
how many of my users
are going to become disengaged.
So anything above-- I
think a good rule of thumb,
again, is about three seconds.
After three seconds, a user
is going to become disengaged.
And we can figure out globally
where these users are.
So I'm from Australia.
Things are really slow
in Australia, generally.
And it's no different for
this particular application,
although I think these
statistics are faulty.
840 seconds is a long time.
I don't think things
are that quite bad.
But yeah.
So yeah, going back, let's talk
about network requests now.
Why are things so
slow from Australia?
OK, so a good first step,
if you haven't already,
is setting up monitoring
for your back end,
or your front end.
Both are good.
This is just the way
to add an uptime check
in Stackdriver monitoring.
And after you do that, it'll
send a request every minute,
or however often you want, and
give you a graph like this.
So it's important
to note that these
are actual timings
from Stackdriver,
not an average of all
of your user requests
or anything like that.
So this is really good for
detecting if your app is up,
and getting a sense of
how long things are taking
on your back end, but
it's only measuring things
from the perspective of
the Stackdriver probers.
These are not actual
timings from your users,
so it's really not that useful.
It's good for keeping
track of uptime,
but not for identifying issues.
So how do we identify
issues using tracing?
And those user metrics
are really important too.
So now we're sort of diving
into this remote processing,
like, whatever's
happening on your server.
Why are things
happening so slow?
Why are the requests
taking so long?
So Stackdriver Trace
is the way to do this.
This is enabled by default
for App Engine standard,
and this app is actually
an App Engine standard app,
and you get this nice
dot plot graph showing
requests over time and
whichever ones were sampled
and sort of where they are.
So on the y-axis is
the latency, and you
can see some of the
requests are getting up
there over that sort
of three-second mark
where we're getting concerned.
And generally, the slow ones
are the most interesting ones
to see, to look at.
And you can actually click
on these specific dots
to look at the traces of
those specific requests.
And there's also this
sweet auto-reload thing,
and you can see the
traces come through live.
Another really interesting
view in Stackdriver Trace
is this latency profile.
So the graph in
orange is this week,
and the blue is
the previous week.
It's actually really
interesting that SAP has such
a consistent latency profile.
I'd expect these things to
change a fair bit week to week.
But yeah.
This is a really great way
to see how many of your users
are in sort of each bucket
that you care about.
So there are some users
above that three-second mark,
and you'll be able to see
the percentage of people
that are becoming disengaged.
The comparison is also
interesting to detect
regressions in your
application performance.
So Stackdriver also
produces reports.
It will provide sample
traces for each sort
of percentile buckets.
So again, I think the most
important ones to look at
are the slowest ones.
So this is a single trace.
This is one of the slower ones
inside this particular app.
Running on App
Engine standard, you
can see it's doing a bunch of
memcache, data store requests,
and then sort of nothing happens
after the one-second mark,
right?
We have no idea what the
application is doing.
So what happened there?
I don't know.
I haven't instrumented
this particular app.
But using the Stackdriver
API to provide custom spans--
so each of these particular
timings is called a span--
it's the way to do that.
There's also Zipkin integration,
so if you're already
using Zipkin for traces.
Well, if you're using--
who here is tracing already?
OK, that's a pretty good amount.
So if you're using a
tracing product already,
there might be an
integration with Stackdriver.
With Zipkin, you can
send all of those traces
to look at them
in this great UI.
But yeah.
So how do we mitigate
these slow requests?
So for example
here, maybe there's
some sort of processing event or
something like that happening.
We don't know.
So how do you mitigate them?
I think a really good way
to, and if you can afford to,
is to write these requests
to low-latency event
queues in other services.
So I'm not going to teach you
how to create an event pipeline
or anything like that, but
what I'm essentially suggesting
here is to store these
payloads somewhere else
temporarily before you can
process and ingest them.
So make those client
requests asynchronous.
I've talked to a bunch
of people outside who
are using App Engine.
Task queues are
a really good way
of doing this, very
high performance.
You can put those
requests in there
and process them with
a push or pull queue
as you have capacity to do so.
The rate that you do that might
rely on whatever underlying
services you're using.
So if you're using
DataStore, for example,
you might only want to write
100 requests per second
or something like that.
Cloud Storage, Spanner, and
Pub/Sub are also really good.
Spanner and GCS Cloud Storage
have multi-region modes,
which means that if your servers
are globally distributed,
you'll be able to write
into those quickly.
And REST support for task
queues is coming soon,
so you'll be able to use
those outside of App Engine.
So maybe we identified
a function or a handler
that's performing poorly.
I think the next thing to do
is to profile that function.
So pprof is a open-source
tool from Google
for visualizing and analyzing
that profiling data.
You get the profiling
data through other tools
like Linux's perf tool.
And this is generally good
for things that are CPU-bound
or I/O-bound or
something like that,
and you can figure out
exactly what's happening.
So on the left is the output
from the pprof command line
tool, basically see
the top functions.
You can dig in deeper
through different methods.
And on the right is a very
complicated graphical output
which shows you
basically call graphs
and how long things are taking.
I think the larger boxes
are things that take longer,
or where more CPU time is spent.
And another really great
way to visualize this
is using a flame graph.
So the colors actually
don't mean anything.
I think that's where the name
"flame" comes from, though.
Basically the width--
and the x-axis
isn't anything to do with
time or anything like that.
The wider the block,
the more often
it shows up in stack
traces for the profile.
And at the very top are the
things actually spending
CPU time.
So this is a good way to
identify potential things
to fix.
So in this one, I don't know,
optimizing text template
or something like that,
maybe adding a caching
layer there is appropriate.
So after you've figured out a
particular functional method
that needs to be
improved, benchmarking
is a really good
way of doing this.
I always say to profile first.
Otherwise, you're kind of
benchmarking in the dark.
You really want to figure
out what to benchmark first
and find problem areas.
It's also really important
to replicate these
results in production.
So production
environments vary--
like, differ greatly
from your workstation,
in terms of their
performance characteristics.
So there's things
like hypervisors.
There was an interesting
story, I think a couple of days
ago, about the
gettimeofday syscall
taking a really long time on--
it wasn't GC, but
another cloud provider.
So you might have problems
like that that only manifest
themselves in production.
So you really need to run these
profiling and benchmarking
on your production environment.
Generally, these VMs have a
lot of raw processing power.
Obviously, it depends
how big your VM is,
and there might be different
characteristics for writing
to disk or anything like that.
Like, if you have SSDs or
a network-attached disk
or something like
that, your application
might perform quite differently.
Another way your application
performance might change
is under load.
So it's really, really
important to do load testing.
I worked on an application
a few years ago
that completely fell
apart under load.
It ran really quickly when
a small amount of load
was sent at it, but
once it was replicated
and out in production, you know,
many, many different clones
of the service, it
just didn't scale,
once actual load was sent at it.
So this is a good thing to do.
OK, let's talk about
getting close to your users.
We're going to talk about
network latency now,
basically, so the request
and response latency.
OK, so back to
Stackdriver monitoring.
This is another
interesting plot.
The one I showed you
previously aggregated
all of the latency profiles from
all of Stackdriver's locations,
but this one splits
them out separately.
So you can see here the orange
line, which is generally
at the top, or the
pink one, which
is Sao Paulo and
Singapore, respectively,
are the slowest ones.
Presumably that's
because this application
is hosted in the US or
something like that.
So this is a really
good way to get
an idea of how your
application performs
across the globe from
your different users.
So you might not
actually care about this.
I was talking to someone
who has an application only
for US users.
This is not going to
be useful for them.
But if your Google
Analytics tells you
that you have users across
the world, the poor sods
in Singapore or
Australia or whatever,
the app is really slow for
them, and maybe you had no idea.
But this is giving
you an indication.
And if we zoom out this graph--
this is another production app,
by the way.
I won't say which.
But if you zoom out, you
also see these huge spikes
across the week.
I have no idea what
happened there,
but this is another
great way to figure out
when to dig in a little more.
It's interesting that this
application spiked only
in certain regions.
Why is Singapore so
slow for over a day?
There's also a lot of variance
from the other regions there,
too.
So maybe there was an outage
or something like that.
OK, so now you've figured
out where your app is slow.
The thing to do is to figure
out where your users are,
put things close
to them, whether it
be front-end servers so you can
serve out your content to them,
or back-ends so maybe
replicating, distributing
data that's important for them.
So for example, if you
have users in Asia,
maybe you want--
you probably want
to store their data
closest to them
so that they can access
it really quickly.
Maybe also replicate it
across to other regions,
but it should be
available close to them.
So this might be something
like a read-only replica.
And you'll have a trade-off
here between lowering
latency and data consistency
across the world.
A write that happens
in Asia, it's
only possible to make it to
the US 200 milliseconds later.
So if a user in the US is
trying to read from it,
they'll see something different.
You can't beat physics, right?
So there's trade-offs
to do there.
One really easy way that will be
available soon to mitigate this
is using Spanner, which will
have a multi-region database.
So that was actually
demoed this morning,
the multi-region database.
So that will
hopefully make things
quick to access from any region.
OK, so once you have all these
servers across the world,
you need to use load balancing,
and the Cloud load balancer
gives you intelligent
routing based
on the location of the user.
And so if the closest instances
don't have enough capacity,
then it will send the request to
the nearest region after that.
So you'll always be hitting the
closest servers to your user.
It also gives you things like
automatic logging, including
latency statistics.
So from the perspective of
the load balancer, how long
did things take?
So this is really good.
And it's a pretty
easy thing to enable.
And it also integrates
really well into Cloud CDN,
which is not really like
a traditional CDN where
you give them all of your
assets and they distribute them
across the world.
But it uses Google's
globally-distributed edge
points--
points of presence,
sorry, and they cache
HTTP traffic and requests
closest to your users.
So caching things at the
edge of Google's network
provides faster delivery
of content while reducing
serving costs.
So these requests aren't
being sent across networks.
It's closest to your
users, fast, and cheap.
So these are the
points of presence.
I think the blue dots,
the dark blue dots,
and the blue lines
represent Google's network.
And there are many
peering partners as well.
So it was mentioned in the
keynote this morning, actually.
So the peering partners
mean that it's likely
there's only one hop between
your users and the content
that you need to serve to them.
And this also means that
as much traffic as possible
is sent through
Google's network.
So even if that
request does need
to go from Asia to
America, it's happening
over Google's network.
You've heard all about the
excellence and performance
of the network this morning.
But yeah, this is a
really great way to go.
So it's really easy to enable.
On your load balancer config,
you just hit a check box.
I don't know why
you wouldn't do it.
Maybe if you're concerned
about content being
stored in different places.
But just hit Enable or
run this GCloud command,
and it will just work.
And by "just work"
I mean you need
to do a little bit of work.
Not all HTTP responses
are cachable.
It will only cache ones
that meet these criteria.
So in short, there's a bunch
more inside the documentation,
but basically it needs
to be a GET request.
You need to set cache headers.
It needs to be, like, an OK
status code, essentially.
And you need to set
a content length.
And it also can't be a
large request or anything
with a set cookie header.
So this is good for
static assets that
is going to be common
across multiple users,
doesn't have any
personalized information
or anything like that.
Another really cool
thing you can do
is set URL maps inside
the load balancer.
You can basically say send
requests to my back-ends,
and send static requests to my
Google Cloud Storage bucket.
And obviously, all of that
gets monitored and logged,
and it's fronted by Cloud CDN.
So what you need to
do there, if you're
backing URL paths
with Cloud Storage,
is to set the cache settings
on your Cloud Storage bucket.
Basically you want to say,
cache all of these assets.
They're not going to
change very often.
Maybe you don't care if
they get cached forever.
You can be clever about
changing URL paths or something
like that if you need
to flush the caches.
There's also ways to flush
the caches at the edge nodes.
That's in the
documentation as well.
So this should reduce
the latency, particularly
for users that
aren't anywhere near
the zones of your back ends.
OK, so I'm starting to wrap up.
We've looked at various
aspects of application latency
or perceived
performance, comprising
the performance of these network
requests, whatever is happening
on the device, including UI
updates, whether you can do
any tricks to send
things asynchronously,
both on the front
end and the back end,
and getting close to your users
to reduce that network latency.
OK, but importantly,
make it fast enough.
Remember that story
about creating blogs.
Don't make it too fast, because
your users might get freaked
out.
Take a completely
holistic approach.
You might have a front-end
and back-end teams.
Make sure they're
working together
to reduce the apparent
latency for your users.
Measure their actual latency
from your users' devices,
and test from real devices.
You can use things
like Charles Proxy
to introduce packet loss and
latency and load bandwidth.
There's also ways on the Android
and iOS simulators to do this.
Collect timings and metrics
from your actual users,
and instrument your back ends
with tracing so you can figure
out exactly what's going on.
Consider your user's
location, device
and networking capability.
So again, simulating packet
loss is a really good thing.
Figure out how your app
performs in poor conditions,
and use global load
balancing and CDNs.
That's a really low-risk
way of making things faster.
But above all else, focus
on user satisfaction.
If your users are
happy, then you probably
don't have to do
anything, right?
Making things faster,
you have to think
about what impact that's
going to have on your users.
Maybe you can better
spend that time
that you would have
spent on performance
working on a feature
or something like that.
If you have the luxury to have
multiple performance engineers
or something like that,
then this is great.
Just keep investigating.
Figure out where things are
coming from, and mitigate them.
And that's it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]